[Music]
so
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back
baby it's that day our draft day for the
season 15
hot ones hot sauce lineup but it's not
just the new
sauces that i'm excited to talk to you
about i have an announcement
you've waited long enough but it's time
in season 15
we return to in studio guest that's
right
it's a day i've been waiting for for a
long time i know that you have at home
as well
and things may look a little different
around here when it first starts but my
hope is
that we return to the classic look and
feel of hot ones
as soon as possible and when you have a
new season
you have to have new sauces so here they
are
our 10 sauces for season 15
back in the studio back to work and here
are our heroes
in the lead-off spot the classic what
can i say about this sauce that hasn't
already been said
it's our ricky henderson our ichiro
suzuki
our lou brock our tim anderson if there
is a better
lead-off hot sauce i have not tried it
the classic it stays at number one and
then
at number two we go from red to green
courtesy of a newcomer to the hot ones
family
holla peppa chef josue rivas channels
the flavors of peru to create this
mild and tangy sauce it combines
jalapenos and aji amarillo peppers
it's absolutely delicious and then from
red to green
to black expect the unexpected here at
hot ones and that goes for our number
three sauce cantina royale's tamasa
you may recognize cantina royale from
season 11 with tamale pika
chef julio he's back this time with the
sauce that's a mix of smoke
garlic manzano chilies think of it
almost like a spicy
chicken garlic bread if that sounds good
to you the tomas is the sauce for you
and then at number four hot ones fans i
know that this is the one that you keyed
on
right away that familiar ombre bottle in
a different hue
introducing the brand new los calientes
barbacoa
pay homage to the ancestral roots of
barbecue this sauce right here
it's a remix of a remix of the sauce of
summer
you have chipotle lime an extra hit of
roasted garlic
it really does balance that smoky and
sweet in the perfect way
unofficially it's the official sauce of
grilling and chilling
heatness.com heatness.com to get your
hands on los calientes barbacoa
and if we've moved los calientes to
number four you know what that means
it means that we have a new number five
and we traveled all the way to ontario
canada for our new midway
sauce it is the ginger goat the original
goat's ginger goat sauce lives up to its
name with a roundhouse kick of ginger
plus
sweet smoked pineapple and then you have
the slow
burn of carolina reapers that's right we
have carolina reapers in the five spot
that's how we're doing it in season 15
taking no prisoners and now it's on to
the back half
and here at number six high desert
teacup masala out of arizona maybe one
of the most unique sauces we've ever had
on the show
garam masala spices whipped coconut milk
and then some fire roasted tomatoes
basically turn a chicken wing into a
curry with a quick toss
and then that blend of ghosts and reaper
peppers really should hit guess about
halfway through their answer
to hard-hitting hot ones questions such
as like for example
our memes art all right on to number
seven
it's a familiar maker you may remember
hotter than elle's go sauce from season
12 now the jacksonville based sauce
maker is back and cranking things up
with love burns
a vinegar forward peppery heater with
garlic
and lime and then of course in the
eighth spot
to borrow a phrase from theo vaughn get
that hitter boy
the bomb beyond insanity a sauce whose
reputation
looms larger than hot ones itself holds
it down in the eighth spot
yet again the heavyweight champ the best
there ever was
the goat the legacy lives on
and then at number nine get your dancing
shoes on because we're going to the
disco
the scorpion disco from karma sauce
trinidad scorpion
ghost chocolate habanero 7 pot primo
it is a pepper party and you are invited
and then here it is finally we've made
it to the finish line
the last dab the gold label the apollo
the top of spice mountain it's the piece
de resistance the only sauce in the
world with smoking heads apollo pepper
by far the hottest dab we've ever
created fresh peppers
dried peppers pepper oil you don't have
to if you don't want to
but everybody kind of does all right
and there you have it it is the season
15 hot sauce lineup
if i do say so myself from the labels to
the colors
to the way that it all blends together
perhaps to the eyeball test
the most magnificent hot sauce lineup
that we've ever made
and it does bring the heat there you
have it
another hot sauce lineup on record
another season of hot ones
on the horizon i'm excited i hope that
you're excited
i know the crew's excited especially
camera guy bill
bill what do you have going on here i
feel like there's always something up
your sleeve whenever we have a new
season on the horizon
i thought you'd never ask sean in my
offseason i like to hone and perfect my
skills
i've mastered the art of cross stitching
i've mastered the art of cooking past
hot ones guests favorite dishes
and now i've mastered the art of
mixology bill you never cease to amaze
me what do you have going on over here
i thought you'd never ask sean in this
past offseason i caught up with
masterchef arone sanchez and he taught
me how to make the perfect causatory
spicy margarita what do you say
that sounds good to me you know that's
my go-to drink summers by the pool so i
can't wait for those days to come back
around again i'm excited to try the
drink let's do it let's get our vacation
on
first you're going to take your shaker
fill it with some ice
and then you're going to take some
sliced jalapeno i know you're not scared
of these how many how many thinking you
like hot things right yeah yeah
you just dump it in there okay there we
go careful around the eyes
oh jalapeno down so since we're making a
double we're gonna do
a one ounce of orange liqueur
[Music]
one okay next we're gonna do an ounce of
agave
nectar here's the best part we're gonna
do three ounces of causadores
blanco or as i like to call it liquid
gold
there's one
there's two
[Music]
there's three next we're gonna squeeze
in some fresh
lime juice none of that canned or
bottled stuff too much sugar you know
nothing but the best for you sean
appreciate it there you go give it a
squeeze
whoa okay
i'm gonna pop the top on give this a
shake like tom cruise a cocktail look at
that
okay now you're gonna take your salted
rim
glasses and you're gonna fill those up
with some ice so i'll give you that one
thank you
okay we're gonna strain watch out
there we go nice
[Music]
and to top it off we're gonna do a
little lime wheel
don't let it roll away okay
and there you have it it's the perfect
causadore spicy margarita
this looks delicious bill i have to say
i'm very impressed
salud salud cheers to cazadores
to hop one season 15 to the fans
and then of course to you bill who would
have thought not me
not me either hot ones fans we'll see
you
very soon
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update
los calientes barbacoa it's finally here
baby this sauce right here
evokes all the flavors of barbecue but
then with a smoky mix
of serrano and habanero chilies perfect
for slow roasting meats
perfect for slathering on burritos
grilling vegetables
get your hands on los calientes barbacoa
heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to order
all summer long we're having the remix
of the remix
hot ones barbacoa the unofficial
official sauce of grilling and chilling